okay so we have these
two guys in the ring and
we know already how to solve the
illumination equation the illumination
equation
we don't measure radians we measure
intensity it's not really
a unit in physics it's just some hacked
up thing that
happens to work in the rendering
equation
we measure radians and we have to do
some kind of integration and
this is if you
the more you think about it the more
impossible it will sound
to even the thought of solving this
problem
so the first question is what can i earn
by solving this equation because i have
to be motivated to do it
so obviously the result better be better
look really good
in order to give me the motivation and
the resources
to solve it so this is an image
from the first assignment and this
we have computed with recursive ray
tracing so you can see for instance
heart shadows
and you can see that this is a
reasonably boring image i mean
it's great compared to the
simplicity of the model that we have but
it's it's not really the greatest
well what is missing let's take a look
and look very closely
let's take a look at the very same scene
but not with recursive ray tracing but
the global illumination algorithm so not
the illumination equation
but the full rendering equation take a
look at the difference look closely
this is full global illumination
ah finally absolutely beautiful let's
take another look
this is recursive rate racing and global
illumination so apparently there are
some effects
that recursive ray tracers cannot
account for
what are these effects well we have
talked about
indirect illumination or color bleeding
this is the very same thing
this means that i am hitting two diffuse
objects
one after each other is this visible
enough okay i'll just pull a bit
on this curtain so you guys can see
better
okay perhaps a bit better right
yes yeah okay cool so these are
in this case ldde paths what's that what
does it mean
everyone knows you start out from the
light source you hit two diffuse objects
and you hit the i
excellent now indirect illumination is
all around us everywhere both in the
real world
and both in the better computer games
out there
which have approximations of indirect
illumination and you can see that on the
left
image it almost looks like photoshop it
is
completely
alien from its surroundings it is almost
as if
it didn't take into consideration its
surroundings so you're standing in
in the fro in the middle of the desert
not just somewhere
you would have to have some color
bleeding effect that you get from
yourself
and this is what usually the problem is
with many of the photoshopped images you
just rip out the person from
somewhere and you put it in another
photograph and it looks super fake
and yes mostly because of the
illumination conditions
but even if you try to account for that
even if you try to recolor it to have
more or less the same color scheme than
than the rest of the photograph
you're still missing the indirect
illumination effect and and the
human eye is very keen in recognizing
that
so you recognize that something is wrong
but you don't know what exactly is
missing and it's usually
indirect illumination but there's
something else
let's take a look at this scene with
recursive ray tracing so we have
refractive materials
for instance this flask sphere on the
left the mirror sphere in the middle and
the completely
diffuse sphere on the right let's take a
look
at how the very same scene looks like
with global illumination
this is the difference one more time
recursive retracing
and global illumination so like
we have talked about this before i can
see the differences in indirect
illumination
so on the on the upper left i can see
that some of the red
color is bleeding onto the other wall
and the very same with the green wall in
the background
also with this diffuse ball so even
a simple diffuse sphere looks
much more interesting and much more
beautiful
with global illumination don't say
anything
but i say something else i see something
else as well not only
indirect illumination i see some other
effect on this image
that i couldn't compute with raytracers
before don't say anything
raise your hand if you know what i'm
talking about
excellent almost everyone and what don't
say anything
okay i'm talking about this
and this so this interesting
light effect on the wall and below this
the glass sphere so raise your hand
again if you know what
what what this is exactly okay don't say
anything
because so many people know you will
have to say
all of you at the same time after three
got it okay so everyone
one two three what is this
the solution
okay what are the other guesses
that's technically a fraction yes but
that's not how we call the effect
anyone else okay this is what we call
caustics
so what what kind of light path is this
this is an interesting light path
in this case this is l ssde
why because we start out from the light
source we hit the glass sphere
from the outside then we have refraction
we hit it from
the inside and then we hit some diffuse
object that is either this checkerboard
down there or the red wall on the left
and then to the eye and if we have this
effect
then we are going to have caustics it's
a beautiful
beautiful phenomenon in nature
that we can finally account for and it's
and and you can you can see this at many
many places
now let's take a look at another example
this is
the famous school corridor example
from black sander again with recursive
ray tracing and global illumination
so you can see lots of indirect
illumination this this
reddish light on
the floor and perhaps some caustics or
at least caustic looking thing
in front of the lockers okay so next
question
what is the definition of shadows again
so what we have said before that
shadows are regions that are not visible
from the light source
now an alternative definition of shadows
is the absence of light
this is what definition we will use in
global illumination so
there's you could say that there's no
such thing as shadows there's no
uh that's that's not something that's
just
the absence of something else if there
is less light somewhere then there's
gonna be
shadows so this is the definition of
shadows in global illumination
and in zen culture
and take a look at this image we can see
some beautiful beautiful soft shadows
and the thing is that you don't even
need to do
anything to compute these in global
illumination so if i have a ray tracer
what do i do
i shoot out shadow rays from these
regions and i try to approximate what
regions
of the light source are visible from
this point
in global illumination you don't need to
do anything you just solve this equation
and out comes physical reality and
shadows are parts
of physical reality you don't need to do
anything in order to obtain shadows
it's it's not like a bottom-up approach
like ray tracing
so you start from the baseline and you
add more and more hacks to account for
more and more effects
and for global illumination you will see
that we will have a simple algorithm
that can give you all of this and you
don't need to account for shadows and
caustics and all of these things
another beautiful example of caustics
this is caustics from the point light
source
because for instance you can take a look
at the shadows the shadows are hard so
it's likely to be a small or a point
light source
and the caustics are very sharp so they
have the same behavior to
large light sources as shadows
and another beauty with caustics
okay so let's assess what these
recursive ray tracers are
are capable of doing and what they
cannot well obviously
they cannot compute indirect
illumination
indirect illumination means two diffuse
bounces or possibly more
this you cannot compute correctly we
will talk about
why and you cannot compute caustics well
caustics i have written in a few
scenes ago that it was lssde so
two specular bounces until the diffuse
because you have to go through
the glass ball and here i'm writing
something completely different i just
say
one specular bounce is necessary the
rest are optional
is this true or how can we verify
this is true
in order to find out if this is true or
not
i don't even need to say a word i can
just do this
do you see the caustics
inside
my fiance is gonna kill me
okay you two have seen it
got it yeah
thanks
okay so apparently
rings have caustics well i start out
from the light source
i hit one specular object one
mirror-like object
and then a diffuse which is the table
and then the i and i have caustic so l s
d e
is enough for constants there's no
need to prove it in any other way just
take a look at physical reality and let
it be your question always